all right we are now doing another live
reading from my book uh reason fulfilled
by revelation the 1930s christian
philosophy debates in france and today
is kind of a big day for readings
because we are
finishing up at long last with the
nearly 100 page introduction to the text
which i wrote
so pretty soon we're getting out of the
stuff that i myself wrote and we're
gonna get into the things that other
people wrote and then i
translated um i'm much happier with the
translations i think than i am with the
introduction so we have two sections to
finish out here
tomist proponents of christian
philosophy
and non-thomas proponents of christian
philosophy and you might say well that's
you know
isn't that everybody who's a proponent
of christian philosophy no because we've
we've already talked about some of the
big heavy hitters like
etienne joson
and
jacques mariten and maurice blondell and
gabriel marcel as separate sections
because all of them were so
important for all of this and now we're
going to talk about some let's call them
lesser known but still important tomists
and some other lesser-known but
important non-tomists and you might also
say well why divide them along that
lines i think i'll put that off until i
get through the reading and we'll we'll
talk about that maybe
as an important topic why tomism why is
that the dividing line so
no further ado here we go
tomist proponents of christian
philosophy
a number of thomas took positions more
favorable to the notion of christian
philosophy
some do not go much further than
registering agreement with jill sohn and
mara 10 but others particularly those
influenced by or appreciative of
blondel's thought make significant
contributions of their own
all of them are clearly committed to the
view that authentic interpretation of
thomas's thought supports and leads into
christian philosophy
he's the first one
the salshwar dominican already began to
use and discuss the term of christian
philosophy prior to the debates both in
a 1930 article sir calca
and in his 1931 book santa monsta kin in
his first foray into the debates la pour
philosophique de christianism he
suggests jill song so as to do honor to
christianity too much minimizes the side
of the ancient world contesting his
interpretation of medieval christian
appropriations of ancient philosophy on
two main points
he argues aristotle's conception of
divinity was closer closer to christian
and specifically thomas conceptions
aristotle's seeming polytheism and
reality tracing back to a first mover
this in turn being more thought thinking
itself that is the good and in some way
the first being certian also points out
that since technically speaking and in
thomas's view quote the world has always
existed that is the reality of the
moving universe is co-extensive with
time itself aristotle's commitment to
the eternity of the world is not
incompatible with and simply does not
adopt an explicit position on creation x
nihilo
during the societe thomas session his
position starts taking firmer shape by
distinguishing several possible types of
christian philosophy
a first legitimate in itself but not
readily accepted as philosophy in our
times or even after thomas's
articulation of the distinction between
philosophy and theology is philosophy
subordinated to faith and being used and
developed within a theological scope and
project
he suggests a second form by
acknowledging thomas's distinction
between the philosopher and the
theologian's stances
differentiated by object principles and
method and asking quote what prevents a
christian thinker from proceeding
precisely like the philosopher of whom
saint thomas speaks namely taking as the
object of his study nature and man
considered in themselves while still
receiving the data of faith as facts
with the same status as experience
in a third more radical form exemplified
by blondel's philosophy quote once one
recognizes the supernatural takes part
in the real dynamism of nature even
though philosophy is not sufficient to
discern it and is still less to
penetrate it we can still ask whether
philosophy must not direct itself
towards it
taking up the essence state distinction
but framing it in terms of the order of
research or discovery and the order of
demonstration
he concedes that
christian philosophy of the jill sonmara
10 type quote while living in a
christian regime has nothing christian
in its notion itself
but then argues that this indicates the
need for the sort of internal
metacritique of philosophy itself that
the blundellian position contributes
culminating in philosophy's openness to
christianity
in on christian philosophy translated in
this this volume again granting that in
the strictest sense there cannot be a
christian philosophy certian argues the
pertinence and even necessity of a
broader use of the term he emphasizes
that historically the christian religion
through increased contact with the
intellectual circles of the ancient
world and through the work of
philosophers who are also christians
unfolds in more and more explicitly
rational forms he stresses again that
while the documents central to the
christian faith do not constitute a
philosophy as such
they employ philosophy as a tool or
vehicle
for the philosopher who is a christian
however there is the additional
possibility of indeed desire for
a project of quote disengaging
disentangling the philosophy latent in
dogma
the heart of certian's own position is
that christian philosophy goes out to
encounter with faith in such a way as to
articulate itself with it
arguably certian goes beyond even marcel
and blondel in his assistance insistence
on the need for a quote philosophy of
the real and by that fact the real
philosophy
re-articulating the argument blondel
made decades earlier in the letter on
apologetics
sirtiage notes that philosophy can
completely abstract from the object of
faith but mutilates itself as philosophy
in the process by refusing to consider
not only the revelation that is a fact
but also that which is a possibility
including the natural calling to a
supernatural destiny
which sertian calls a positive
possibility and picks out as a theme of
thomas's thought going farther he argues
that these questions require exploration
not only in general but quote in detail
of all the forms that our theoretical
and practical practical activity
presents
including the entire gamut of
philosophical sub-disciplines these he
frames as
philosophy as a whole considered under a
certain relation
that is not by consideration of what we
possess
but relative to what we lack that
towards which we strive
certian thus advocates for the role of a
blundellian philosophy of insufficiency
one that would find itself inevitably
coming into contact with christianity by
full exploring itself philosophically
discovering its own indigence in the
process
all right the next section
a may foret
in the society tommy sessions first
presentation officially devoted to the
historical problem of christian
philosophy foret noted that entanglement
with normative assumptions about reason
and philosophy was unavoidable for two
sets of reasons
first reiterating a blondelian point
reason and by implication philosophy and
religion are both uniquely unrestricted
possessing a common preoccupation with
unity with totality
with reason and faith philosophy and
christianity we are no longer in the
presence of notions which express only
one aspect of being
second any conception of christian
philosophy presupposes a judgment on the
nature of knowledge that faith has us
reach but already an interpretation of
reason
of its value its scope its specific role
the problem at its most general is
therefore that of the relations between
reason and faith everything he says
depends on the interpretation one gives
of both of these and of their
relationship
farrett discusses three possible
attitudes separation
reduction of one to the other or some
kind of union
only for the last attitude is christian
philosophy possible
after signaling jill songs and
mauritan's contributions he advocates
further philosophical progress through
showing how reason becomes welcoming to
data of faith how born on by its own
movement it strives in some way to go
beyond itself in affirmation of the
supernatural
a long developing tradition of french
philosophy including blondel's work does
this and foret makes two interesting
points
first he worries that the base upon
which these doctrines are set is perhaps
a bit too narrow to sustain the entire
edifice of christian philosophy because
it involves reflection more focused on
the human subject itself than on
properties of being as such and on the
transcendentals more still on the traits
of spiritual life of belief of action of
morality than on consideration of
substance
second he suggests that tomism provides
not only a necessary counterbalance but
prospects for a more complete christian
philosophy
quote it belongs to tomism to
re-appropriate this continued tradition
of french philosophy and to enrich
itself from the results obtained by
rethinking them according to tomism's
own principles
next section
a.r matt
the second society tommy's presentation
begins by explicitly granting
christianity's historical influence on
and fertilization of philosophy and
suggesting quote let us simply place
ourselves wide open before the integral
reality and let us look at it
this injunction is emblematic of mott's
presentation whose main argument echoes
forests and foret's insistence that
tomism faithful to its method and
inspiration is robust enough to
assimilate non-thomas positions for
christian philosophy and generate a yet
more complete position
early on he faults those who hypostatize
thomas's distinctions between the
natural and supernatural orders quote
falsifying the balance of his doctrine
by leaving too much in the shadows the
traditional augustinian if you like
element that this discovery completed
but did not at all repress
the concrete unity of the world the
object of the soul wisdom that would be
adequate to it christian wisdom
the unity of being bears implications
for metaphysics and moral philosophy
both of which have as their object
integral reality the totality of being
this gives philosophy a certain
pascalian grandeur coupled with misery
stemming from quote a paradoxical
disproportion between its object and the
crudeness of its
implement as thomas revealed being and
transcendental notions are co-extensive
with the whole of reality leaving
nothing outside of themselves the
transcendentals and the analogical
relations of beings perpetually present
difficulties for the philosopher which
however can be avoided or explained away
only at the cost of abandoning
philosophy's true vocation accordingly
the philosopher once he ascends from
common being to its principles to its
final principle definitely collides with
mystery this mystery reveals to
philosophy its determinant
insufficiencies creation obedient
potency the angelic world ultimate
finality in eschatology and history's
interpretation mark points where reason
sees its object escape it and matt
speaks of zones of obscurity invoking
the marcellian notion of paradox
mott draws three further implications
out of philosophy's entanglement with
integral reality first unlike the case
with other disciplines
philosophy does not exist
there are only philosophies and
philosophers
who reflect on the same problems but do
not end up in bringing their solutions
to the degree of evidence which would
convince all minds
thus radicalizing implications of jill
sons and mariten's positions he adds
philosophy can only subsist in the
symbols that express it or in the minds
that think it
plurality and capacity for progress and
development will then be involved in
christian philosophy
second making a blundellian point in
thomas terms mod argues that the
condition for preservation of
philosophy's autonomy is its engagement
with the whole range of realities of
which it becomes aware even if this
means philosophy must then take account
of its own insufficiency and seek means
for its completion outside itself
third he emphasizes perhaps overlooked
elements of christianity's contribution
to philosophy and reason it provides
philosophy a quote precious means to
critique and complete its metaphysical
reading of experience
the christian philosopher through faith
and theology is also brought into
communication with the realities in
which he believes placing him in a
better disposition towards the things
which he knows in some way
connaturalized by his faith
christian philosophy induces in the
philosopher's soul a quote special
quality of reason the form of curiosity
the surplus value of penetration and
certainty deriving from faith and moth
ends by speaking not only of christian
philosophy
but
of christian reason
all right the last tomist
proponent bruno de salaj
who is translated here
the most explicit attempt at
reconciliation of the positions of
joseon maraten with blondels his
contribution begins by summary of the
debate's development the central issue
from the historical point of view being
the influence of christianity on
philosophy
once the fact of this influence was
generally agreed the question of its
nature and its legitimacy comes to the
fore
he is particularly interested in the
nature of that influence returns to the
question he put to joseo and agrees that
christianity's influence does not
exercise itself in the way the influence
of philosophical systems does since it
confronts the philosopher with truths
derived not from rational activity but
from supernatural
revelation
this granted the problem arises whether
christian philosophy has any right to be
called philosophical and desolace
introduces the first of his alpine
metaphors the philosophical climber
ascends either with or without a
theological guide and the guide can
either drag the climber up or simply
indicate the proper path for him in the
former case the philosopher does not
ascend by his own rational powers and
ends up in theology
but the in the latter while aided by
theology he still produces philosophy
in a second metaphor the paths thus
traced
thus far represent trails blazed by
jilson and mariten turning to the
blundelian trail which focuses
philosophy on the problem of the
supernatural arguing the need for a
quote predestined empty space that only
the existence of a supernatural order
and its revelation can come to fill
disolaj elaborates his analogy
of the paths none of the three lead to
the same peak for our mountain has three
peaks
but it seems to me that the view that
one has from each of them marvelously
marvelously completes the view that one
has from the others and that all three
allow one to make for oneself a
sufficiently complex and exact idea of
this complex reality
this complementarity of perspective
reflects a more structural
complementarity in which the jillson
mara 10 position implicitly requires and
is completed by the blondel position and
vice versa
all right
next and final section in this
introduction
non-tomist proponents of christian
philosophy
atn born also translated here
his undeservedly neglected contribution
to the debates makes several important
points a philosopher's basic attitude
towards christian philosophy depends on
the totality
of metaphysical meta-philosophical
commitments comprising what born labels
his reflexive philosophy
christian philosophy is dismissed as a
possibility by those who dogmatically
assume quote philosophy's progress is
analogous to tracing a line that follows
itself out infinitely owing nothing to
anything other than itself
never returning to itself and
ceaselessly adding something new to the
old
reflection attentive to experience in
history however indicates
that non-philosophical data of a wide
variety of ranges of types and orders
upon which reason and philosophy work in
irreplaceable ways reciprocally and rich
in form and extend rational activity
what an adequate reflective philosophy
tells us then is that progress in
philosophy
depends
on deepening understanding of perennial
truths and
more fully engaging human experiences
ranges of data
christian philosophy of jill sones or
maritan's type in which reflection on a
datum acquired by intuition or all the
more received by grace and in which
metaphysical analysis will discover an
intelligible intelligible aspect without
striving after its profound mystery not
only is legitimate but reflects
philosophy's natural progress and
capacities
born rejects a position similar to
blondels which requires that philosophy
not only be
open to the supernatural but also be a
quote restlessness not a science
culminating and making philosophies
insufficiency the fundamental truth of
christian philosophy
this represents philosophy's abdication
of its own proper tasks and functions
quote philosophy suffices onto itself
and it establishes an order that has its
internal and original justification he
writes but this must be balanced by the
quote fundamental truth of reflexive
philosophy
namely that philosophy does not suffice
under the fullness of the human being
and must therefore be located within a
hierarchy of orders
under such conditions philosophy
in its very nature will find the
implicit desire unknown to itself for
living in a christian state
michelle suryo
the earliest protestant participant in
the debates
surya devotes his efforts first to
critical examination of brahir's
rationalism
second to more robust development and
defense of the augustinian tradition as
christian philosophy he turns brahir's
own criticism around by noting that
quote rejecting christian philosophy he
carries out apologetics for greek
philosophy he then identifies three
governing assumptions of the
rationalists
first philosophy's rationality is
non-reflective it must neither attack
nor measure reason's share
second philosophy is secular
third it is in the end a scientific
culture a study of the cosmos a
correspondence with the reality of
things
in other words excluding the
supernatural it is a physics in the
ancient sense of the word
given these assumptions philosophies and
christianities irreconcilability follows
but
no cogent reasons are given for
accepting them
against joseon surya agrees with
criticism of tomism which he holds
admits alongside christian faith a
closed reason a system that contains
spirit in the world uninterested in
defense of brahir's other targets
including blondel he instead advocates
closer and less dogmatic study of the
augustinian tradition and argues quote
the solution that augustine accepts in
the end is not a system
following on other systems it emanates
from a point lacking an intellectual
dimension from a new practice it makes a
purely interior life the life of the
spirit come forth
accordingly no philosophical system is
augustinian which signifies that
augustinianism is philosophy and
movement asking what is the distinct
meaning of the word christian in the
expression christian philosophy
he sets it in an imitation of an
assimilation to christ from which
augustine derived a quote psychology of
spirit's activity and a metaphysics of
pure thought
finally uh
let me make sure uh yeah honoree no two
we have two more honorary guillermo
conceiving of himself as like briar and
jill some primarily a historian of
philosophy guilier nevertheless made a
minor contribution to the debates
asserting that two questions which could
be dealt with separately had been bound
together
what historically was christianity
christianity's influence on
philosophical thought and what would be
the possible content to place under the
expression christian philosophy
these could be dealt with separately and
he does so addressing the first he
espouses he exposes a philosophical
assumption within history of philosophy
a discipline quote never historical
because it places at the origin of every
thought another thought and not the
unpredictable encounter of a man with a
reality naked before him
the actual origin of a philosophy is not
another philosophy but a discovery of
the world so that a philosophy is more
an unfolding of something
non-philosophical than a spring for
another philosophy
where one might expect gujir then to
cast christian philosophy as a rational
unfolding of ideas stemming from a
christian origin he holds
area that christianity does not act
directly on philosophy but philosophy
finds itself in a world where
christianity exists along bergsonian
lines
he suggests further research into the
bearers of creative emotion who animate
christian philosophy and into the quote
representations of which christian
emotion is generative
turning to christian philosophy's
possibility
reminds the interlocutors rationality is
the essential character of philosophy
rationalism or a rationalism is its
ideal
rationalization is its life
he then distinguishes between two
different generic philosophical
attitudes philosophies of truth and
philosophies of reality
quote a philosophy of truth explains and
demonstrates and therefore must set
aside any religious datum inserted into
a network of supernatural episodes since
it remains by its nature recalcitrant to
rationalization
but
whereas one demonstrates a truth one
points out a reality one concludes to an
existence one encounters a presence
a philosophy of reality permits more
robust engagement with christianity
because quote the problem of the
religious irrational is raised within
the interior of the philosophical domain
and not at its entrance
not only are the historical existence
and the claims of christianity reality's
philosophy must account for and
investigate but quote if the philosopher
is christian
his christian consciousness is a reality
he encounters
such a philosophy can be a christian
philosophy and guihere advocates the
term christian philosophy the hyphen
marking the continued impregnation of
the noun by the adjective
this would be a quote philosophy
christianized by the presence of reality
that is the christian history of man and
his relations with god
finally
louis paul kochette in a series of
articles late during the debates 1934 to
1935
kochet does several interesting things
first he notes the philosophical
implications of the very interest in the
problem he writes this problem being
brought back under study actually marks
a date one where for the first time
since the middle ages christian
philosophy reappears as an attainable
goal and as a realizable ideal
seeking after christian philosophy
involves deepening and revitalizing
philosophy itself reorienting it to
become a quote effort of the human mind
to see clearly within the real and
orient itself to its destiny
second he re-articulates the relations
between several key philosophical
positions and systems in light of the
problem of christian philosophy
cochette argues the complementarity of
jill sons and blondel's position but
frames them in relation to augustinian
and thomist approaches to the christian
philosophy in a unique way
both of them have contributed to raising
the problem of christian philosophy by
revealing the limits and the
insufficiency of these two traditional
systems of explanation and by showing
that only a synthesis of tomism and
augustinianism will be able to resolve
the difficulties and to elucidate the
problem
the synthesis will not simply return to
medieval philosophy for quote the
thomist and augustinian methods reveal
themselves as insufficient because in
modern times the systems of rational
speculation to which they are tied are
shaken in their very foundations
what is needed then is the sort of
fundamental reconstruction of philosophy
blondel advocates and carries out
and cochette's interpretation of his
thought represents a third interesting
contribution
blondel carries out a labor of
assimilation of modern philosophy by
christian thought analogous to those
which in their time saint augustine
carried out for plato's philosophy and
saint thomas for that of aristotle
accordingly
it is blown down who by systematically
developing a new
christian philosophy responsive to the
demands of modernity is faithful to
thomas's example and who in an original
manner has answered the call of the
encyclical by tierney potress
a fourth contribution is decidedly
koshet's own assigning a new timely task
to christian philosophy
if one wants as a philosopher to unify
one's thought in a conception of the
totality one must assimilate the data of
science as those of faith and bring them
back by reflection to the infra and
ultra human real so as to provide an
integral perspective on them
and with that we end the introduction
we are now at the
section the debates begin
and ready to
launch into emil brelies
is there a christian philosophy
published in the review to metaphysic
into the morale
volume
38 number 21 in 1931 which is the first
of the translated documents in
this book so um we're gonna do that next
time next thursday
and it's uh nice to finally be done with
the introduction all right so let's see
what we've we've got here there's a
retracted message which i think was
about style
and then there's another one here um
did translation teach you anything about
philosophy broadly construed
so this was not my first work in
translation
in published translation i
as a graduate student i translated
some works
from some articles from french into
english
for
who were they for it's been such a long
time
um and you know you learned some things
along the way um therefore some people
in in continental philosophy
and then i did some some paid
translation work for the book that
became uh i don't know what is it i'm
blanking on that one uh varela was one
of the people in it and i think the pros
on being aware
i also became involved in the thomas
aquinas translation project that was for
a while based at the salz
university
uh under uh
stephen laughlin
and that was quite interesting
translated uh portions of thomas's
as yet untranslated um
commentary on the psalms there's a
french translation of it but a full
english translation is not yet available
and in that there was a collaborative
project in which we would read each
other's translations and comment on them
and often discuss them and get into
interesting theological discussions i
also helped out with
some of the little eposcolum and some of
the sermons
and then i translated from german
some stuff for some of my classmates um
provided those those
were just like
structures that were then given to other
people to use for their translations so
for example mock shalers or kentness and
arbite my
grad school colleague zach
davis took a look at my translation as
he was doing his translation of that
and
you know i provide my own translations
and articles on epictetus or aristotle
from greek so
you know one thing that you do learn is
that each language not only is each
language its own language each author
has their own way of doing that language
and so you know
to bring this this question to a close i
i will say this
ferdinand de saussure
in um his court linguistic genral you
know of course in general linguistics
one of the very first things that he
says early on is that if you want to be
a linguist
learn a lot of languages
why because otherwise you're going to be
full of crap when you generalize about
languages because you're not going to
know what you're talking about it's sort
of like if you want to you know be a
sports commentator
don't just watch football watch baseball
watch you know hockey watch other
non-team sports because otherwise you
don't really know the field
that well
i think that for anybody who's doing
philosophy of language or semiotics or
any other thing that's connected with
communicative activity
if you don't actually study and
live a little while within different
languages
you can't do your work effectively
and translating is a really great way
of doing that
by translating you also learn to be a
little bit more charitable
towards many other people's translations
where you're like well i wouldn't have
translated it this way but i can see how
they got that you know like for example
the book you see behind me there
miller's translation of the
phenomenology of spirit
um i will sometimes you know say miller
i don't know about this translation here
but i guess it works the german is
actually
this
you also you know can very quickly tell
when a translation is off the rails in
its badness and then you don't have to
cut that any any slack
so it leads to a certain kind of
ethical comportment i guess you could
say
translation is also really a really
great way to get to know an author you
know you are
you're doing something
mostly with dead authors in my case that
allows you to spend time with them and
think about how you can take their words
in their native tongue
and bring them into your own
so other people can make sense of them
and
you know it incurs a responsibility upon
your shoulders
in doing so
that i i don't think all translators
necessarily
honor
um
but you know translation is is a
it's a it's a task
and you do it over and over and over
again i like doing it because
i don't have to think original thoughts
all i have to do is figure out how to
make somebody else able to speak in my
language
you know
um
and so i i find that very
rewarding i don't get enough time to do
it anymore because i don't get enough
time to do anything because i do so many
things
but yeah so there's
i don't know does that teacher teach me
anything about philosophy broadly
construed i guess you have to be the
judge of that
um well anybody else like it puts
questions or comments about the topic or
the book or things like that i'll circle
back to the issue of
why thomas versus non-thomist
so within catholic circles
in large part because of the influence
of the attorney potress and the
institutional support
provided to this revival of tomism
and the problems with
other
attempts at at you know sort of a
christian philosophy going on in the
17th and 18th and and
19th century
like you know traditionalism or
ontologism or the various cartesian you
know christian philosophies or things
like that tomism became sort of the
not the official but the predominant way
of doing
philosophy within catholic circles and
so for the french establishment which
was very anti-catholic
um
tomism also became like its own kind of
like little we could call it a ghetto
and
sometimes this was a good thing because
thomas is a very interesting thinker who
has a lot of
you know engagement and flexibility in
his thought there's a lot you can do
with thomas if you're not like a
doctrinaire
thomist but it also left the door open
to a lot of abuse and you see this
sometimes with some of the
thomas figures of the you know
from 1900 on through 1950
where um basically
they think that they understand you know
tomism and and uh christianity better
than anybody else
and um anybody who's outside of the
thomas circle is is a modernist or you
know crap like that
um
and i you know i've encountered some
people like that in real life who are
still around today and i've encountered
some of those in doing the research on
this and in doing research on blondel
who particularly drew the ire of we'll
just call them crappy thomas like that
but was also as we saw um taken up and
viewed as sort of a great innovator by
many people who were in fact homeists
like antonin sertian or
bruno de salaj or amy farrett you know
some would actually go so far as to call
themselves disciples of blondel
so
this line between thomist and non-thomas
probably not that relevant today
but it was very important back in that
time a
major line of distinction so
all right any
questions comments things you want me to
grapple with we got a little bit of time
before i got to get to setting up my
classes for fall for fall semester
that's rapidly approaching
some of my classes are starting monday
and
are not quite where i want them to be
um
okay did you have to worry about
researching thomas philosophy through
other thinkers is reading always
infected with other readings
um
i read thomas i've been reading thomas
for 25 years so half my life in latin
and
you know um
when i when you know my my measure for
tom anybody's tomism is how faithful is
it to saint thomas himself
um so no i that's not a worry for for me
um what's interesting is you see the
range of different interpretations of
thomas some of which at certain points
you're like yeah i've been buying you up
to this point but i think you're
actually off the course on this
there's actually a
book chapter in a book by ralph
mcinerney atomist which is called too
many tomisms described in the 20th
century and all the different varieties
of of tomism that there is now is
reading always infected with other
readings i wouldn't use the word
infected
because that's pejorative but every
reading that you do of course is
bringing other readings that you've done
and other assumptions that you're making
and
teachers who may have told you right
things or teachers who may have told you
silly [ __ ]
all of that is coming to your your
reading there is no pure you know
reading
that's pristine as a matter of fact um
this is this is a constitutive of how we
actually do reads so
here's a question about muslims did the
muslims add something to philosophy sure
but nothing that is
relevant to this other than you could
take some of the
you know distinctions that are being
made by some of the thinkers and say
okay how do things play out within the
larger
muslim civilization which includes the
arab world and the iranian world and
extends all the way to india and then
comes all the way over to
spain and the translation project and
all that sort of stuff
um
yeah i mean every everybody's adding
things we we know that there's
interesting confluences not only between
say greek philosophy and islam but also
even in the bactrian kingdoms you know
that were left behind by the the greeks
that alexander had between that and
and uh indian philosophy
um
the stories of
philosophy in the world are pretty
broad and wide you could say
columbus uh can you talk more about
maurice blondel about his thoughts on
rationality
um i mean blondel like a lot of these
other thinkers
thought that rationality is not
something that we should just like
assume it's something that we develop
and
um we can be irrationally rationalistic
right we're like reason consists in just
this you know i i've read a manual const
critique and now i know exactly what
reason is and you can well
if he was so right then how could there
have been a hegel or a schopenhauer
after him you know or anybody else
you get these very doctrinaire
rationalists and blondel was was very
much
keen to undermine that and to say
sometimes the most rational thing it
goes all the way back to pascal or all
the way back to augustine or even justin
martyr is to say
oh man we don't actually have it all
figured out um part of rationality would
be extending into the things that seem
irrational and trying to see what we can
assimilate from them so that's that's
one of his his key thoughts i would say
um ricky says i'm surprised christian
philosophy would mention eschatology
that's not a big surprise they mention
everything i mean
christian christian philosophy if it's
about you know engagement with
christianity eschatology's part of that
all sorts of things are part of that so
that's not a big surprise
uh eunice what do you think of renee
ganon i think traditionalists are mostly
[ __ ] um
and i don't pay much attention to them
so
you know that's that's not really
relevant to
to this stuff though
except that right here is criticizing
the earlier traditionalists so
all right any other questions about the
book the topics the thinkers
i've read augustine's confessions i
don't feel compelled what do you say the
big contributions of his work to the
canon of philosophy
um well obviously those chapters at the
end on the metaphysics of time and
memory
right i mean that's
big stuff right there the book could be
read just for those
um lots of meditations on the nature of
evil it's a narrative account of how
somebody
uh came to be a
christian and a you know his seeking
through philosophy and and how all that
fit in that's right there
uh places it in
in the canon um
i don't think that we have to
necessarily justify
um
bringing works into the the canon
by saying oh this is the big
contribution this is the big
contribution
um but
yeah mean augustine has been part of the
canon really since
augustine was around
so
you know with somebody like that you can
actually say why wouldn't he be in the
canon you know why wouldn't that work be
in the canon by the way i'll mention
that that one of my uh
friends and and colleagues from a long
time ago paul griffiths
when he was um
a professor at university of illinois at
chicago where
i was actually interviewing for a job to
become his junior colleague but didn't
get it he took me to his uh introduction
to catholicism class and interestingly
in that class
i said well what are your textbooks that
you're using because he was teaching
like philosophy and catholic studies he
had a joint appointment
and he said
augustine's confessions
thomas aquinas portions of the
somatiologia
and pascal's passes and i was like
you're just doing those three and he's
like that's enough
we get so much mileage out of those
um
you call them who's ever got a book then
found it in a bookstore for less after
you got it
sometimes
uh
but yeah
oh here's a good question
is rereading your book bringing up any
questions or problems for yourself i
find my older writing becomes either
myopic to something i think now or
lacking style
no um i mean
it's worth reflecting on the fact that
this was a product of eight years of
continual research and translation and
writing so if there were like you know
if there were any glaring errors they
got worked out every once in a while i
find a typo
um so the copy editor for university or
catholic university of america press
obviously wasn't doing their job
but uh no i think it's
you know the book did what it was was
supposed to do i i wish that i could
have
included more
uh contributions to the debates in it
but i had sort of a
your manuscript gets to be this long and
that's it
kind of limit
um but it's uh i mean for what it was
supposed to do i think the book is uh
pretty good
um
and you know most of the book is just me
translating these other
writers from from the time so you know
there are a few i'll mention this this
is kind of a funny uh point so in the
uh society detude philosophy session
that was held about blondel's um
uh
book that came out in 1932 the poblano
that was the philosophy catholique
there was this guy
devil vay and he was very difficult to
translate because he is a
terrible writer
and
when they were they had somebody like
review my translation
and they they picked on that particular
section and they're like this is not a
very good translation and i was like you
try translating this guy you know let's
see how good your translation is devil
of a was like just uh all over the map
you know
um
and it's sort of like when you're when
you're doing uh podcast editing if the
sound quality isn't good at the start if
you've got an echo in the room
you ain't gonna be able to take it out
somebody is not a great writer to begin
with the translation isn't going to
sound that great you know unless you
unless you fudge unless you change
things you know which maybe some people
do
what are your thoughts on the influence
of heidegger and the 19 christian
1930s christian philosophy debates there
was zero
he was not important for that at all
remember heidegger published being in
time in 1928 he was he was not a
important figure until much later
and heidegger is not involved in the
french christian philosophy debates
um
[Music]
so
i mean heidegger would fall into the
group that said you know christian
philosophy is an oxymoron it's like
wooden iron and
he's kind of inconsistent on on that
point
um but he has he has nothing
there's no real involvement of heidegger
in this
somebody who does get brought up is mock
shaler
and if you want phenomenologists who
were involved in the question of
christian philosophy
it would be edith stein
gabriel marcel who is
translated in this book
um
leo noel who's also translated and uh
the benedictine uh foiling
uh in the society thomist
second day of studies edith stein was
actually in the first day of studies the
society thomas devoted its first annual
session to examination of edith stein's
phenomenology so
so heidegger was not an important figure
but other phenomenologists were
in the debates
any other questions comments
concerns issues
[Music]
all right well maybe we'll wrap this up
a little bit early next session
reminder we're going to do
um
we're going to do the first actual
translation from it by emile brellier
the great rationalist historian of
philosophy who was kind of a young punk
at the time
making his bones here's a final one if
you're translating as philosophy did you
think did your do you think your
department was a good fit for that my
department didn't care one way or the
other i have i have not had a
department that actually cared much
about what i was doing
um most of my career
if you know my story
i started out after you know finishing
graduate school
teaching in a prison for ball state
university for the department of
philosophy and religious studies and so
long as you know things kept on track
they didn't care what the hell i was
doing or have much interest in it
because they were over on the other side
of indiana from where i was teaching
and then when i was at um
fayetteville state university we didn't
even have a philosophy program we only
had a philosophy minor we were teaching
three to four critical thinking classes
each semester i was doing in you know
academic leadership and business ethics
and stuff like that while i actually
published this my colleagues thought it
was cool that i published a book but
they otherwise didn't care one way or
the other when i was at marist college i
was an adjunct and
nobody cares what adjuncts are doing
right except at the place where i'm
still teaching now
which is um
milwaukee institute of art design
and
they're just happy that i'm bringing
philosophy and you know some other
classes in as electives for their their
creative uh type students artists and
designers
um so
you know i'm i'm not at like a research
department or something like that where
they'd be like oh we we have this great
person here who's translating you know
duns scotus or you know pascal or
somebody like that um
people are more interested in are am i
showing up to classes and teaching them
are the students actually
learning something
um
[Music]
so
here's here's an interesting one if a
friend of mine once told me if you want
to understand christian philosophy read
dante's inferno well no you wouldn't
read the inferno you would read the
whole divine comedy because reading the
inferno without the rest of it is uh
you know you're only getting a little
bit of the picture right it's a triptych
um and dante sure you can read dante or
you can read thomas or you can read
pascal or you could i mean why why
single out dante i guess if you like
dante then he's the guy for you but why
would you restrict yourself it's sort of
like saying i'm only going to eat
chinese food the rest of my life and i'm
only going to eat uh one particular dish
why why would you restrict yourself like
that
so all right so we'll we'll say no f now
next next time um getting into the
translations from this book thanks for
all the questions comments and i'll see
you
uh
down the the line um
there we go i had to move the window a
little bit to find the end stream